on passait à la face cachée de rohff on
va faire une interview bisounours
eh bien ça va apaiser le débat c'est
noël tous c'est quoi votre couleur
préférée
le noir est votre fleur préférée celle
que geoffroy ma femme la rose
est un sentimental
alors découvrons ce qu'on connaît pas
avec mon heure pleine et entière du
muguet
c'est quoi pour vous la soirée idéale à
c'est gênant répond pas
lâche moi je mange pas de ce pain là
c'est pas le fan qui va moins je veux
soir idéal c'est quoi c'est pour me
faire manger des pommes de terre les
meilleurs accords de tiers de booba on
est plus fabuleux comme veba la chose la
plus romantique que vous ayez faite dans
votre vie rohff
il a offert un bracelet électronique
gaza
c'est ça
c'est quand j'ai fait la demande en
mariage ouais à l'ayraultport arrêt au
steward
quand vous étiez petit votre doudou
c'était quoi je n'avais pas un pas deux
sessions temps qu'ils quittaient tango
dos quand
tu as beaucoup jouer ton ticket beaucoup
est ce que
[Rires]
c'est le rend ma vie avec mes yeux
est ce que vous êtes désespéré par la
disparition des ours polaires et des
pandas
non
faites vous un bisou et
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux